una avalancha de reacciones o casi no el
cierre de la adquisición de Twitter por
parte de elon musk El multimillonario
dijo que restauraría la libertad de
expresión en la red social y el
vicepresidente del Consejo de Seguridad
de Rusia
fue uno de los primeros en reaccionar
buena suerte de la superación del sesgo
político y la dictadura ideológica en
Twitter y deja ese asunto de starlink en
Ucrania la comisión europea por su parte
dijo que Twitter tendrá que acatar las
normas del bloque esto en respuesta al
tweet de Mask que decía que el pájaro se
libera en referencia al logo de la
plataforma en Europa el pájaro volará
según nuestras reglas
bretón con toda la razón era simplemente
recordar Cuál es el marco que debe
cumplir cualquier empresa que opere en
Europa hay ciertas actividades que no se
ajustan a las normas reglamentos y leyes
de los estados miembros en particular
como usted muy bien señala cosas
relacionadas con la incitación al odio
con actividades delictivas con el
terrorismo etcétera etcétera
el ex presidente Donald Trump que fue
bloqueado por la red social dijo estar
contento ya que Twitter ya no será
dirigido por lunáticos de la izquierda
radical más que no ha ofrecido detalles
sobre cómo luchará contra la censura en
línea mientras protege a los anunciantes
de información sobre quién dirigirá a la
empresa Aunque dijo que nombrará un
consejo de moderación de contenidos con
puntos de vista diversos el empresario
que dirige la compañía de vehículos
eléctricos tesla y la empresa de cohetes
spacex planea convertirse en el
consejero delegado interino de Twitter